well
it's a great rainy day but a wonderful
time for adventure the nichols family
is headed to whittier to go rent a boat
to sail the seven seas
are you guys ready little scurvy sea
dogs yeah
what a beautiful day to go out on the
ocean
becca are you excited to get hypothermia
and seasickness
i get seasick
all right let's do this
yeah that's good all right guys this is
it
dad's sealing the boat
have rented this 22 foot fishing boat
for two whole days
and uh we're gonna camp on it and we're
gonna see glaciers and hopefully whales
and seals and maybe catch halibut or
rockfish or salmon
we can do whatever we want because it's
our boat so you guys excited
yeah this is going to be adventure
becca here is prone to seasickness and
she is the best sport in the world for
coming along with me so hopefully
we're gonna have calm seas well guys i'm
gonna try my best to drive the boat and
film at the same time because this is
one of the most beautiful
places in the world whittier alaska is
gorgeous we've got waterfalls
glaciers mountains emerald green seas
it's just
amazing and the wildlife is just off the
charts
you ready to go a little faster yeah
what do you guys think of this
me nathan and tommy did a really awesome
hike through these mountains
and camped on a beach called emerald
cove
we're filming videos up here in alaska
for six whole weeks
and if you guys want to see lots of
other adventures
well from our trip up here to alaska
i'll put a link in the description to
that
all right guys what do you want to see
first you want to see sea lions puffins
whales glaciers glaciers
all right well i know a good spot to see
some calving glaciers let's go check out
the glaciers and uh if we see some
animals or
fishing along the way we'll check that
out too
is this beautiful becca you're beautiful
becca
got some bait right there that looks
pretty good well i'm seeing some good
signals on the sonar but you know what
we've got this thing for two days let's
go uh let's keep
looking around just had a salmon jump in
front of us
oh yeah there's a big old glacier on the
mountain right over there
i mean we can see whales anywhere in
here hey jacob what'd you see
we're in 1200 feet of water right now
[Music]
look boys iceberg ahead
oh you guys are going to see a lot more
icebergs than that hold on
there's a glacier that's falling into
the ocean over here
oh look at that waterfall
look at this look at the size of this
glacier
this glacier is so huge it looks like
we're right up close to it
but it really it's a half a mile away
and it's just
enormous why not
so we are right here at the foot of a
glacier
look at that we can't get too close
because a big chunk falls off it'll
cause a little tsunami
this is just awesome people oh
wow
rebecca is this cool this is cool
i'm glad i came here i'm so glad you
came
whoa this is much better than seeing
this with like 200 tourists on a glacier
viewing boat isn't it
true i think the only thing that could
make this cooler
is if we caught some fish which sounds
like a great idea
guys should we get some ice for the fish
cooler yeah all right let's
let's get some glacier ice we are going
to eat some of it
okay let's see if we can find a piece
nice catch all right couple million year
old
glacier ice
how's it taste it doesn't taste salty at
all
oh that should do it
everyone hold on
there's hundreds of nesting birds right
in here
look at this they got they're just
nesting right up there in the rocks
i've seen a few salmon on the fish
finder not a ton of them but a few of
them
so we're gonna cruise around here and
see if we can't uh
find some fishing these glaciers are
everywhere we've already seen like three
or four
and there's another one right here we're
gonna go up to
there's tons and tons of these glaciers
in prince william sound
i don't even know how many you got to
watch what you're doing around here you
don't want to hit some ice
i've got a history of doing that nathan
you need to use the potty
yeah the one little issue with this boat
doesn't have a bathroom but they do have
a five gallon bucket and a toilet seat
all righty
[Music]
we've got a little island here and a
steep drop
off next to it we're gonna see if we
can't see anything on the fish finder
got some bait fish or something down
here oh
there's a signal there's something you
want to catch a fish jake
all right we're gonna get you a fish man
looks like the rain
is relenting for just a little bit got a
fish
jacob take him reel him in this
[Music]
oh touch
[Music]
[Music]
hold on tight to that rod though buddy
there's
monsters in here but you got oh we got
one oh
man oh oh keep that rod up tom
holy crap you ain't joking he just
stripped a load of drag
that didn't look very big and all of a
sudden oh my oh well
that's uh that means you might have a
nice salmon on there
oh do you see that look at him he's he's
just roaring drag
oh
that is a beauty that's a king salmon
buddy
that's my first one all right let's get
him let's get him in here
that's a beautiful king salmon buddy
that's a lot of food
it's cake salmon because he has a black
mouth and black gums
and he has spots on both sides of his
tail
great cake salmon man oh
oh so much fish slime should we put them
in the cooler yeah
put them on glacier ice way to go
tom oh it hurts so much
whoa
high five dub fishy high five
the hose yeah
[Music]
what is that you look at that tommy you
caught an irish lord
a irish lord see see look at the little
spikes right there
yeah see look at that yeah and the nose
spikes and he's got spikes right there
and sprays in there all right should we
let him go
what you got buddy what do you think you
got keep reeling
another one yeah you got yourself a nice
irish lord
oh a little bigger and
that's a sculpting they call them
sculpin or irish lords
look at him oh he's vibrating vibrating
should we go drive the boat yeah all
right let's do this
oh we're just cruising along and we saw
a big old stellar sea
lion big as a canoe big old boy
were you guys hungry yeah all right
let's get some dinner out here
okay we've got we've got mres for dinner
we have the brisket entree
cheese tortellini and tomato sauce beef
ravioli and meat sauce
ooh the chocolate peanut butter spread
guys
santa fe rice and beans vanilla pudding
dessert powder
okay you got these heaters going all
right
got our mres let those warm up
how do you like the ravioli
i like it and i don't like it oh tom you
got one
oh yeah he's a big one it's a heavy one
you got a lot of really he was down at
220 feet
what is it no that's a cod a cod
yes i caught a cod yes
those are good those are good that's
what we make fish and chips out of
oh oh it's pooping it's
[Applause]
yes we are you got a big one
oh tommy you might have a halibut
oh my goodness hold it don't lose that
rod
you got a lot of reeling to do buddy tom
that's a lean cod
what oh my goodness those they're
there's a it's a very yummy fish called
the lean cod
but i think he's a little small yeah tom
these get a hundred pounds
look at it look at the teeth on him come
look at his look at his teeth
he's unhooked bye-bye
oh there he is it is off tommy
congratulations you got a lean cod
man
well i'll tell you what we have had an
absolute ball but it's about nine
o'clock
and a little past the kids bedtime so i
am going to find a spot over there
to anchor up and uh we're gonna get the
kids ready for bed but uh this adventure
isn't half over i remember this is just
like your plot two boat
uh-oh jacob squished his fingers in the
door
oh my god it does look like you're
really yeah
we're once we me and mommy are ready to
go to bed we're going to switch you over
to this
transformer bed okay all right guys
[Music]
you guys all cuddled in yeah okay
good night okay be good
well the kids are to bed we got things
kind of straightened up and packed away
and
uh now it's just me and the missus i
think we're gonna
snuggle up watch a little movie uh keep
an eye on the fishing rods here and then
i we're gonna call tonight and i'll see
you guys
in the morning
well good morning nathan good morning
did you sleep well
[Music]
well everyone's kind of taking their
time getting up which is just fine so
i'm going to
pull up anchor and kind of move spots
and do some fishing while everyone wakes
up
yeah little baby rock fish it's in the
morning
pajamas in the rain
oh there we go oh that's a greely green
link oh look at the spots on that thing
that is cool here we go get in there
while i was outside reeling in fish all
sorts of cuteness was happening in
teddy here are you with teddy are you
with teddy good morning
hi jacob oh yep look at that
oh it's a dusky rock fish
oh that's that's my favorite rock fish
well we are going to keep him oh the air
bladder
it came fully out it kept falling
well yesterday there was just a little
bit too much wave for becca's taste out
in prince william sound
uh it's supposed to have calmed down
today so we're gonna go head back to
whittier pick up some more fuel
and uh then we're gonna go out and
explore prince william sound a little
bit
maybe uh do some fishing maybe see some
more glaciers maybe spot some whales
let's see what happens
there's a jingle spider in your life
we got a little bit of waves here fun
waves
fun way oh here's one so we're going to
try
a little jog through a bit of open water
to try to get to some other glaciers
and uh we'll kind of see what happens we
got about two foot waves here
which ain't much for the boat
is this is this fun tom yeah is this fun
mom
no
it's my best day ever yeah this is like
a bouncy castle for nathan
he thinks this is awesome some of them
are so big we're like
going through mid-air and slamming on
the water
[Music]
oh
well all three of the kids are asleep
now
hey becca you see that glacier there
those are otters oh yeah look at this
there's a whole bunch of otters
there's an underwater island here a
little hump on the sea
bottom where it goes from 700 feet to 45
feet
we're gonna see if we can't see any fish
on those are traditionally
very good places to fish head ahead
there's some fish it's a little bouncy
here i'm not sure how long becca is
gonna
be okay with this so we're gonna drop
some
rigs down quickly this is a halibut hook
it's just like fishing for catfish only
bigger
[Applause]
[Music]
this one was bouncing i saw that
all right well let's see what it does
iris lord
what we were thinking halibut though
i didn't even set the hook he just
ripped it so
hard not yet oh it's close oh what is
this
oh that's the biggest irish lord of the
trip
oh look at my fist
that is the monstrous irish lord oh look
at that
what he just threw up an octopus we
ready to let him go
yeah all right here you go buddy
look at this
that looks like a giant squid because
look at look at the tentacle
check it out there's like
these are wiggly like tape worms that
that the irish lord puked up
let me catch an octopus oh i got
something big
oh he's actually acting like a halibut
it's a snagged wood
you snagged the eyeless board
oh you got something there tom oh he
spit the hook
he said oh that was a massive irish lord
i think we need to put up these fishing
rods and go look at some glaciers
there's another otter there's just tons
of sea otters there are so many otters
here i can see
dozens of otters look at this
[Music]
they're so cute
jacob are you having fun
all right that ought to do it
oh you got some glacier ice by the
heater you're gonna
you're gonna drink some million year old
water huh yeah
all right we're gonna try drinking
tommy's glacier water here
hmm nice play a slight hint of fish
all right we're going to see how close
we can get to this glacier without
destroying our prop
jacob do you want me to spank tommy why
is that
pick him just pick him okay
[Music]
we are at the foot of a tiny tidal
glacier but when you get up close they
look massive
and chunks of ice will fall into the
ocean periodically and that's called
calving and when when bits of the
glacier cave off it sounds like a
gunshot it's just absolutely amazing
we've had a couple pieces fall off just
when we got here
this is gorgeous isn't it
gorgeous
check it out the water here isn't that
beautiful green color it's that
gray that's the silt from the glaciers
they grind up
rocks as the glaciers move across the
valleys and when they melt
they drop silt
[Music]
oh check it out we got all these seals
resting on the glaciers
[Music]
well that was pretty cool guys you got
your own little snuggle party going on
over there
snuggle party
all right tom let's see if we can catch
another fish before we have to leave
[Applause]
yeah let's see what we got all right
it's a rock fish
oh look there's a dead salmon here bring
him over here
bring him over here look at that his
eyes popped out
well it's been a fun trip but it's time
to give the boat back
and get it cleaned up so i've got some
fish to clean
oh you catch something pull them up what
you got
oh you got a card hey thanks for playing
all right we made it safe and sound back
to the dock i didn't wreck or break
anything
you got this everything who had fun on
the boat
[Music]
all right guys come on come on man we
had a great time we hope you guys
enjoyed watching this video if you guys
want to see more videos
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching